heute besuchte verteidigungsminister
hans peter fokussiert das militär 100
zentrum in kaisersteinbruch hier wurden
sieben rottweiler wirken getauft durch
das umhängen der dienstplan werden die
jungen militär hunde symbolisch in den
dienst gestellt und beginnen die
ausbildung zum bach und schutz und
verteidigungsminister fossil sowie der
boden länder landeshauptmann hans niessl
und landesrätin astrid eisenkopf
übernahmen die patenschaft für jeweils
einen der welpen das militär
hundezentrum im burgenland züchtet und
bilder dienst tun das für das bundesheer
aus aktuell werden 186 militär hunde
darunter größtenteils rottweiler sowie
schäfer und labrador hunde für aufgaben
im in und ausland eingesetzt